okay so checks I said this is an LED UV
flashlight we just bought this right
here and I got my two masks right here I
want to show you how many particles and
viruses I may potentially have on these
masks take a look at this this is a mask
I got today at yard house when I ate
over then I forgot this mask they gave
me this I don't know if you see it or
not all of those things to be particles
right all of those look get all over the
place this is what's on my face and this
stone I use and wash occasionally I wash
right check this out you go over here
okay it's very obvious a lot is on it
right okay so why am i showing this to
you right now here's why because we just
got water from Governor Abbott today on
the Texas that we are required to our
mask at work now it's the requirement
that we're supposed to wear masks unless
of certain things you have a you know
breathing issue or certain conditions
that you have you're required to be worn
a mask right okay no problem we'll go
ahead and listen a word the mask when
you're looking at all these masks people
are asking a lot of different questions
and I went out there research myself I
got some stuff I want to show you we
will look at how CDC and World Health
Organization is telling us how to
properly wore a mask and I want you to
tell me yourself while you watch this
when's the last time you wore the mask
the way the experts are telling us to
wear masks I even have a video of a
doctor showing how to wear a mask and
this poor doctor is looking here first
then she looks here then she look you
can tell she has all the steps on how to
teach us how to wear masks and she needs
a step-by-step process on how to
properly put a word I'm asking and I'll
give you some data here but let's go
through this year together okay so first
of all how : 19 spreads two different
ways one is the for my transmission
which is what I'm touching this stop
somebody came over here there's
particles I touch my nose boom I got
coronavirus hypothetically the other one
is respiratory article particles that
reach you directly this is sneeze cop
six feet three to six feet you cough I
get it oh my gosh then I have it a
couple of days later I'm having symptoms
I may have Corona bars no problem then
they tell us there's three different
masks to use right the lowest level
masks are these this is a cloth mask you
see a lot of people using bandanas
work as well but that's considered the
cloth mask then it's these masks which
are the surgical masks but they're not
recommending that we use this because
they want to save this for who doctors
nurses and the last one is the n95 mask
which I don't have one here but this is
what it looks like writing a lot of
people contact me saying Pat I can get
you a hundred thousand I can get you
five million do you want to buy and sell
this to some people and here's what you
got to do now these are the masks that
we're looking at what the CDC is not
recommending us to use are these and
they don't want us to use these they
want us to specifically use these now
even though they want us to use this
guess what they're saying they're saying
that they're nurses and doctors cannot
use these because these are not the
safest you and I can use these but in
hospitals they can use it's no problem
let's go through this again what they
say next
so-called mask is what they've been
recommended to use cloth face coverings
are recommend it as a simple barrier to
help prevent respiratory droplets from
traveling into the air and onto other
people through the person wearing the
cloth face covering cotton okay you get
the idea this is called less source
control surgical masks we already
covered we've already gone through what
to do or what not to do now let's go
through what CDC is telling us to do
when it comes down to recommendation
with coverings right here's what they're
saying CDC recommends that people wear a
cloth face coverings and public settings
and one around people who don't live in
your household especially when other
social distancing measures are difficult
to maintain or cloth face coverings may
help prevent people from who have Co
been acting from spreading it to other
people or coverings are most likely to
help reduce of Cova nothing fine
coverings should not be worn by children
under the age of 2 or anyone who has
trouble breathing or is unconscious and
capacitated or otherwise unable to
remove the mask without assistant now
watch this who should wear a face a
clock face covering general public again
same thing two years old Koba 19 spread
few or no symptoms okay so all this
stuff pretty much the same thing we're
looking out over there right no problem
now I want to show you what Anthony
found you who the other day when Rand
Paul called him out and he had his nice
I believe it was a Washington Nationals
mask on he dropped it he put it back up
you dropped it put
which means if there are any particles
on the table he dropped and put it back
up this is the man who is the expert he
went like this and he was about to
answer he went like this then he went
like this you're not supposed to touch
this thing
he net once reached out and said okay
this is what you're supposed to do it
dropped if it drops ok put another thing
here and go back again watch this now
that's Anthony pouch you know here's
what happened he found she said on an
interview with 60 minutes I want to say
March 18th or March 8th take a look at
this formation surrounding face masks
can you discuss that no man there's a
lot of confusion among people and
misinformation surrounding face masks ok
can you discuss that the masks are
important but someone who's infected to
prevent them from the pectin someone
else now when you see people and look at
the films in China and South Korea
whatever you are I was wearing a mask
right now in the United States people
should not be walking around with masks
you're sure that because people are
listen really not closely enough right
now people should not be why there's no
reason to question this when you're in
the middle of an outbreak yeah
wearing the mask might make people feel
a little bit better and it might even
knock a droplet yeah it's not providing
the perfect detection that people this
is our expert and often there are
unintended consequences Dubrow fiddling
with the mask and I keep touching them
which is what you did you got some
schmutz in a thing inside their OS of
course but when you think mask you
should think of health care providers
eating them and people rail but people
when you look at the films of foreign
countries and you see 85% of people
wearing masks that's fine that's fine
against it if you want to do it that's
fine but it can lead to a shorter day
that's the trying to convene a shortage
amassed fair enough so that's Anthony
Fauci our expert talking about the when
two masks work or not that we really
need to do it or not now watch this now
here's a video from someone who is with
World Health Organization showing us how
to properly work a mess now watch this
clean your hands with alcohol-based
hammer and people who have symptoms
suggestive of so watch nineteen before
touching the mask D in your hands with
alcohol-based camera or soapy water
yeah
20 to 30 seconds rub obviously we all do
20 or 30 seconds
soap and water 40 to 60 seconds I'm sure
everybody does that holy moly
yeah I'm asked for tears or holes do not
use a map that has previously been worn
or is damaged they are fine which side
is a talk this is usually where the
metal strip is identify the inside of
the mask which is usually the white side
yeah
place the mask on your face okay
covering your nose mouth and chin making
sure there are no gaps between your face
and a mask
pinch the metal strips so that it molds
to the shape of your nose
remember do not touch the front of the
mask while using it to avoid
contamination if you accidentally touch
it clean your hands okay that's one of
them right that's one of them now watch
the next one year so I'm not even so if
I touch it clean your hands now how many
of you when you go to a restaurant or
place of business how many of you guys
have this with you in your pocket all
the time okay now first well let's just
assume that's that all the time but fine
some of you are saying I'm doing it all
the time great now here's another one
from World Health Organization this was
shot February 5th body watch what she
says it's got a couple million views
medical mass like this one cannot
protect against the new corona virus
when used alone when you wear them to
another protect against the new corona
virus medical mass like this one cannot
protect against the mutant virus when
used alone when you wear them you must
combine it with hand hygiene and other
authentic measures don't you into only
recommends the use of masks in specific
cases if you have called so just
breathing you should wear a mask and
seek medical care sure if you do not
have these symptoms or how not have to
wear a mask because there is no evidence
that they protect people who are not
sick however if you are healthy but you
are taking care of a person who may be
infected with the new piranha verus then
you should wear a mask good whenever you
are in the same room with that person
and remember if you choose to wear a
mask use it and discard it properly and
clean your hands with hockenheim rub or
soap and water for more information on
masks use okay so here's the next one
watch this now here's a lady that does
an exercise which I just showed you here
with the led UV flashlights watch what
happens right here when this doctor is
showing you how much viruses and
particles can be in the equipment you're
using I watch this here check this out
represents a bacteria or germs
viruses so we can demonstrate how easy
it is to spread this even if we're
running into the grocery store with
proper PPE and protective equipment and
grabbing one item okay I have placed my
protective equipment on correctly and
I'm gonna run in and buy some water at
the grocery store so here's my water hey
I'm gonna take my pen and paper you see
yep this is a great example by the way
I'm in she'll be very helpful takes us
it puts it back up with your hands which
is what you do how many times does your
oh wait or go like this go down off my
gloves I want to show you how important
it is that we do this in the right order
in the right way so let's see how I did
I'm gonna turn on my black light here oh
my goodness so starting off we knew it
was on the one surface look at my gloves
my mask right here on my brother am I
gonna set this pin the poor person who
uses this come after me and look at my
hands
oh my goodness the worst part about this
is when I really my mask I did not use
the proper procedure which means that
not nothing I'll make how many people
are using cutting edge right in your
nose and in your mouth
and no is this really close to my nose
okay so no so now watch this
so let me show you the other one now
here's a doctor showing how to properly
use it watch where she's looking at the
end I must speed it up a little bit and
just look at her eyeballs were she's
looking at the entire time enough and
outside this is everybody don't pull
you're not I'm sitting down here it's
always be fitting properly I mean their
thing you don't have an area like this
yeah all of these for continues and
other self descriptive enough up against
three Cheryl hospital or my can also
connect with our Nichols my home makes
us do the same where you put something
that's our one second what I can frame
that's outside your mask you can see
this is incredible fight so that's gonna
find that side of thing when I working
on that we want it first put into some
clean type of course material art
because everywhere we go absolutely you
do all the time what we don't want to do
is the entry
nothing I do it's talking would be
something like our cooks or our pocket
yes I am way too ahead - I'm so cosine
Omega dimension it's just three miles on
mistress okay okay I need to not remove
any or every person I do is command so
I'm not perform can fight you can do so
choir or cancer fighter when I remove my
now I'm gonna be okay when I remove my
neck from secure even so happen again
it's it is and I go ahead and wait for
the way I'm then go ahead when I'm
trying to make you with this case here
obviously she's a doctor
this thing's got six hundred thousand
views it was uploaded two months ago
it's got six hundred thousand views and
it's coming from an expert but even the
expert needs cue cards for her to
remember what to do next and you and I
are not the experts and they're telling
us to go you something like this and
when you put the light LED light on look
at the amount of particles and worse
thing worst thing that we do so let's
just say you go to the restaurant let
you see you're in the market let's just
say you're doing whatever you doing do
you know what's proving that this thing
doesn't work you know what proves that
this thing doesn't work let me give you
an example right here so say I put the
Sun okay here we go
let me do the responsible thing here I
so we got this year at this point of the
game it's been on the table God knows
what's on the table we keep this place
pretty clean but I take this I put on my
face you ready oh here we go
so hey what's going on okay great what
can I get you I like to get a drink you
know what what is it that you want it I
can't do that that's not something you
can do now yeah okay babe so yeah so how
was your date today I work okay it was
great whew yeah okay
oh hang on a second oh it's dad hey pop
what's up boom yeah okay yeah yeah we'll
see you on Saturday yes sounds good
you want me to pick you up something no
great hi you ready pal all of this stuff
that's on this thing here then if all
goes right here are you
are you carrying one of these things
with you when you go to the restaurant
so then both sets another call
hey bro what's going on dude are we
gonna watch a basketball game together
yeah poor absolutely we'll watch it
together on Sunday okay great
put it down third time eat the food
- everything drink ba-ba-ba-ba-ba right
okay thank thank you so much you cut the
pen they bring the pen you don't know
where the Pens been you sign the pen you
put this on your face you grab your
phone you leave what what what is this
protecting right here by doing that what
is this protective right here now I
understand one part about coffin I
understand one part about me give it to
you because the three said three to six
feet social distancing I'm only with it
I totally understand we go by every
single guideline that the state tells us
every time CDC make some changes we go
ahead and do it ourselves right now
right so the mass thing
I don't know fine let's say we follow
the mass let me take it a different
level for you here's some data here's
some data for you okay let's look at
some data let's look at some data so
every knows you're listening to cases
are up we gotta be careful it's the
second common go chrono virus look at
this oh my gosh look how high it's going
Nick at the numbers fifty two thousand
six hundred and nine cases yesterday
right cases cases cases it's all cases
but we're not talking about how many
people died yesterday
watch this it's okay six hundred seventy
people that do you see how this one's
going down this is positive right there
this thing's going down when you go to
cases this thing's going up case is
going up and then you see here that
going down okay what does this really
mean let me break down the numbers for
you so you know kind of what this really
means okay so so far if yesterday we had
fifty to fifty two thousand six hundred
and nine cases okay six hundred seventy
people died if we do the math on this
six seventy divided by fifty two
thousand six own that's about 1.2
percent which means 1.2 percent of
people that get koban nineteen died or
is it really the number but let me go a
little bit further for you total
challenge is two point seven four
million people in America I've had Koba
19 case a hundred thirty thousand people
have died that's four point seven
percent but if you go worldwide ten
point seven million people have had the
case coronavirus five hundred sixteen
thousand people have that which is what
four point eight percent if it's four
point seven four point eight and now is
one point two shouldn't we be
celebrating shouldn't we say good news
percentages are going Lord which means
what it's not as deadly this is basic
math I'm showing you now some people may
say Pat you're manipulating the numbers
tell me why because the way you need to
do it is take the death today which is
670 and go to the amount of cases that
was two weeks ago fine let's do that
this is what 670 people died one as of
July 1st right okay I have 670 here 678
fine okay so if I go to cases and it's
July first 14 days ago is what let's go
to 14 days ago will be what sixteenth
twenty three thousand forty seven which
is what I have here if I take six
seventy divided by twenty three thousand
four or seven it's still 2.9 percent
lower which means it's still going over
this is somewhat of a celebration but
that's now how the media's pitching it
so let me even take you to different
level when we're doing base event here's
a map so when you look at these numbers
and they're saying cases are so high
cases are so high what happened all over
some one case was being high well
Washington Post that's an article on
what day this is Washington pause let me
find it Washington Post I don't know if
you see it Washington Post calm right
investigations on CDC date June 8th
which is less than four weeks ago less
than four weeks ago what did I say here
investigations this is not like somebody
just wrote this article here right
CDC one stage to count probable
coronavirus cases and deaths but most
aren't doing it okay let me read it one
more time
CDC want States to count probable
coronavirus cases so now let's find out
what CDC defines probable chrono virus
cases so let's go to the CDC website
which is right here
what is a code 19 probable case a person
meeting clinical criteria after the
epidemic of a Dem may Allah check our
evidence with no confirmatory with no
confirmatory laboratory testing
performed overnight
let me read it one more time so a person
who goes and meets with the proper
doctor but there is no confirmation that
they took a koban 19 test that came out
positive
none a person meeting presumptive
laboratory evidence and either clinical
criteria or evidence a person meeting
vital records criteria with no
confirmatory laboratory tests and
perform for Cova 19 so in the hell
Washington Post CDC want States to count
probable coronavirus cases which means
how many of these cases that we're
getting are probable cases and how many
them are just cases that were you know
it's real I don't know you probably have
it you know I go to doctor I run six
years ago I lost my voice for a couple
months I went to the doctor three
doctors they said there's a lump here
you probably have cancer you probably
have cancer you probably three times
have you probably have cancer I want to
do surgery they're cut spinout you don't
have cancer probably probably probably
have cancer cut it it's benign you're
good I left before weeks I don't have a
voice but it was probably I had cancer
so you probably have curled a virus you
probably have coronavirus that's kind of
a same thing that we're talking about
here if you look at this data with cases
50 2001 609 here's my question for you
here's my question for you after the six
hundred and seventy people that died
yesterday from coronavirus god bless
their soul I am sure families devastated
with the loss of a loved one we right
now have people in our sales force set
of coronavirus that have been
hospitalized and I'm going through it
with them on the call to see what
they're going through because I want to
hear the challenges they're facing and
they're both recovered and we've had
many of them that have recovered in the
field and we had a couple of them here
that had to recover as well and they'll
be going through themselves so I want to
know what the symptoms are I want to
know what they're feeling I want to
learn myself and I want to do whatever I
can to protect everybody but here's a
question I got for you 670 people died
from corona virus yesterday how many
people you think died yesterday that we
don't know was because a corona virus
let me ask the question one more time
how many people do you think died
yesterday in America who died from
corona virus but in the registry that
input coronavirus what do you think the
numbers most likely zero
because when people are dying right now
hospitals are pretty much required to go
and find out if this person died from
coronavirus or not if they did they say
cause of death what coronavirus but I
got a different question for you you
ready out of the fifty two thousand six
hundred and nine cases yesterday
I've got coronavirus here's my question
for you how many people do you think
right now have coronavirus better
sitting there saying man I went to CVS
they told me wait I'm not gonna wait
forget about it I'm gonna go I think I
got a floor or a coffee it feels like it
I feel like bronchitis maybe I don't
know it just doesn't feel good but I'm
not gonna go to the doctor and I'm not
gonna get tested let me ask the question
one more time how many people you think
at fifty two thousand six or nine
yesterday got a case of coronavirus how
many habit that haven't gotten tested
because they just didn't want to go to
the doctor twice as much three times as
much let's assume you said three times
as much if it's three times as much that
means that 52,000 609 really was what
yesterday 156 thousand if it's 156
thousand you know what it tells us to
are one point two percent at one point
two percent goes to point four percent
that means the death rate is really 0.4%
at one point two percent you know that
number the two point nine percent that
two point nine percent goes to what
point nine percent because it's a third
which means at the beginning when they
said this is three percent three percent
of people are dying oh my gosh five
percent of people are dying the math is
not probable math that they're doing so
if you look at everything combined
together I am not telling you doing one
more we don't wear masks I wore masks
because I'm following guidelines at the
office when everybody comes in we're
doing temperature with everybody on
their forehead nobody comes into the
office until they go through the
temperature we're following every single
thing that is taking place with the
guidelines but here's what's a deeper
concern for me that we're not talking
about the deeper concern for me is the
fact that 45 million people lost jobs
Serkis all ages file bankruptcy a bunch
of businesses that you and I use have to
file bankruptcy because they can't sit
around hoping they're going to be able
to less are we doing the right thing
right
now with so much more fear around to so
many people that are conventions I do
events every year in Las Vegas every
single people I talked to last week with
conventions hotels they're struggling so
many hotels blacks is a black stone that
missed the payment on their first hotel
business that they but they missed a
payment Blackstone missed the hottest
Black's don't miss a payment this is not
a small little company we're talking
about it's wonderful biggest companies
respected company missed payment check
this out
Blackstone skips payment on 20 50 74
million on a hotel on what do you mean
Blackstone skips payment Blackstone is
supposed to be like premier they're
skipping a payment yes they're skipping
a payment why are they skipping a
payment who the hell is going to a hotel
right now who's going to hotel right now
some of the best restaurants you that we
would go to they're just tell me Pat I
we can't afford a name anymore
these are high-end restaurant shutting
down said exactly what we want is it
really what we want so look foutch e if
you're gonna tell us where masks one
minute and a couple months prior to that
you told us masks can't do anything why
are you telling us now if it's just
something to say it's gonna make you
feel better and it's gonna make people
feel calmer fine we're doing it but I
also know a lot of people that are not
feeling comfortable learn these things I
also know a lot of people that are
putting this on say man I can't even
breathe right now I'm not feeling
comfortable about it and also not a lot
of people that are putting this on
they're getting a lot of anxiety so what
is the solution I don't know all I can
say is we need our leadership team to
really start considering every single
person and look at the data a little bit
more and stop using this data here to
manipulate everybody and put fear into
us and start thinking about the small
business owners that 59 million
Americans work for these are not
billionaires these are small companies
with less than 500 employees that 59% of
you fifty nine million people in America
work for if those small business owners
go out of business what could come next
crime things that are really really
scary I mean you saw the other day when
a guy that was marching protesting
across a person's home you saw the guy
that came out with the pin shirt and a
gun you're the rifle you saw the lady
who's a lawyer bought that him pistol
she's holding and later on they came and
said we're so sorry we're Democrats
we're not trying to say anything don't
take anything away from us and they kept
our
all Isis what is there but what is going
on with all this stuff by the way this
is nothing on how ugly can get if people
are hurt economically and if you want to
find a solution being printing more
money which Nancy Pelosi saying let's
send ten thousand dollars with families
with three kids I also don't think
that's the solution because you're
putting us in more debt and the dollar
keeps going lower and lower and lower
and yes who's gonna have to pay the
price for this long term so again these
are data these are numbers I'm simply
showing you stuff that I looked at
you're gonna have to make up the make up
your own mind on what you want to do but
I'm hoping more people will start
sharing information like this and start
questioning everything
am i imposing anything in this video the
only thing on there posing in this video
is question every politician every
expert everybody out there because
they're making big decisions for you and
I to sit there and say you cannot go to
work
your kids cannot go to school people
gotta stay home and there's so many
traumatic things that are happening to
the existing generation the kids now
we're not gonna see the side effects of
it for ten twenty thirty years from now
what we're gonna feel it so we have to
start thinking that we can't just sit
there and say well look at some of these
percentages so what are your thoughts
you saw some of the numbers I shared
with you what are you thinking about
this comment below I wanna hear from you
and if you want to have a real dialogue
with some of your peers share this with
people you know and see what they're
telling you about this having said that
thank you thank you for watching
everybody take care of life
you